[Music]
PT's social study a quick look at what
stars are posting online Justin Bieber
seems sad and single on Valentine's Day
posting this now deleted clip to his
Instagram story Tuesday all you ever
wanted with a Valentine no I don't even
have a Valentine moving on Mariah Carey
had a steamy Valentine's Day celebration
with boyfriend Bryan Tanaka she shared
this taking a hot tub with her shirtless
beau while rocking a black bikini and
holding a glass of wine Mimi also
Instagram these racy shots smoldering in
a spiky bra top in a bathtub I love that
leave it to Kanye West to pull out all
the stops for wife Kim Kardashian on the
day of love oh my god just walked in and
look what I see a huge flower wall with
like orchids and roses the same day
Kimye stepped out an all-black ensembles
for a romantic dinner date in NYC at
Carbon restaurant Kim K stunned in a
black crop top and skirt with a thigh
high slid alongside blonde Kanye in a
matching leather jacket I want to wear
things that make me feel good about
myself and still feel sexy and Ariel
winter may have spent Valentine's Day
without her boyfriend Levi but she put
their romance on display with a racy
throwback from the couple's trip to Cabo
showing her legs wrapped around him in a
skimpy bikini